so we want to take a look at here is
what they're giving us so they're saying
that you know given this diagram here a
B is congruent to a D so let's go ahead
and mark that on the diagram those are
congruent and it says that BC is not
congruent to DC okay good and what we
want to prove is that AC okay doesn't
bisect angle ba D so we want to prove
that this okay does not bisect this
angle ba D okay so when you do an
indirect proof the first thing you want
to do is take what you're trying to
prove and temporarily assume that the
opposite is true okay so do you
understand so you take what you're
trying to prove and you temporarily
assume that the opposite is true so I'm
just going to write this down so let's
just assume okay temporarily that AC
cable just say ray AC does bisect angle
B ad okay so you're with me so far
so then if we're assumed this does
bisect then we know that the measure of
angle 1 is equal to the measure of angle
2 and that's by V definition of an angle
bisector so definition of angle bisector
so this is more of like a paragraph type
proof as opposed to a two column proof
so now we know that angle one is square
root two angle two so I'm just going to
mark that on our diagram and we also
know that AC is congruent to AC okay
it's congruent to itself and that's by
I'll just put in parentheses here
reflexive property right reflexive
anything is congruent to itself and so
what you notice here is that this
triangle this triangle are congruent so
this is triangle V AC is congruent to
triangle G a C and the reason would be
by the side angle side okay side angle
side so now that we know that these two
triangles are congruent we can say that
BC is congruent to DC and that's by the
cpctc which means that the corresponding
parts of congruent
angles are congruent once we prove these
two trials are congruent the parts that
match up meaning BC and DC will also be
congruent okay however what do we notice
here however this is a contradiction of
one of the Givens so whenever you get a
contradiction of a given or something
that you know that is true like all the
angles in a triangle add up to 180 or
you know parallel lines don't intersect
or a known fact or one of the Givens
then you've reached a contradiction so
however this contradicts okay this
contradicts contradicts the given okay
therefore okay that's what these three
dots represent here therefore AC okay
ray AC must not bisect angle B ad and
that's exactly what we were trying to
prove from the very beginning so what we
did okay and what you do with an
indirect proof is you go about it in
obviously like it sounds an indirect way
instead of starting from the Givens like
we normally do in a proof and then
reason logically and order until we get
to what we're trying to prove we're
actually saying hey you know let's just
throw that whole thing out let's just
assume that what we're trying to prove
that that the opposite is true
okay and we reason based on that
temporary assumption okay in this case
we're assuming that EC does not I'm
sorry it does bisect angle B ad this
says does not well we assume the
opposite that it does b8 bisect angle B
ad and you reason from there until you
get a contradiction of the given or a
known fact and that's exactly what
happened here so we said hey you know
our original assumption okay right here
that it does bisect angle B ad must be
false and the opposite is true and so
therefore you can then assume that what
you're trying to prove is in fact true
so I hope this helped you to understand
a little bit better how to work with
indirect proofs subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I'll see you in the next video I'll
talk to you soon